[Music]
good evening I'm Bret Baier we are
coming to you tonight from the Reynold
Reagan Presidential Library in Simi
Valley California more on why I'm here a
bit later in the show we begin on the
other coast however as president Trump
meets with three of his top national
security officials after calling for a
major investigation into reports the FBI
had a plant and informant spy whatever
you want to call it in his presidential
campaign in 2016
President Trump especially wants to find
out what his predecessor President Obama
knew about it
judging by his tweets the 45th president
clearly considers this part of a big
conspiracy chief intelligence
correspondent Catherine Herridge starts
us off tonight with the investigation
good evening Catherine read in a
statement late today the White House
press secretary said there's an
agreement for the president's chief of
staff John Kelly to immediately bring
together law enforcement and
intelligence agencies with congressional
leaders so that lawmakers can view the
highly classified records they requested
long ago a White House official said the
president's concerns about an alleged
FBI informant would be raised at the
meeting which included Deputy Attorney
General Rod Rosenstein who was oversight
of the Russia Special Counsel probe FBI
director Christopher ray and Dan Coates
the nation's intelligence chief after
the president's weekend tweet calling on
the Justice Department to investigate
claims about the informant the
department quickly announced Sunday the
expansion of an internal investigation
into alleged government surveillance
abuse the new line of inquiry will
consider whether there was any
impropriety or political motivation and
how the FBI obtained surveillance
warrants or used informants to collect
intelligence the vice presidential Fox's
martha maccallum the administration
wants clarity and closure the president
I think is grateful that the Department
of Justice is going to have the
Inspector General look into it and
determine and ensure
there was no surveillance done for
political purposes against our campaign
I think it would be very troubling to
millions of Americans if that took place
a source close to the matter tells Fox
News that the Republican chairman of the
House Intelligence and oversight
committees Devon unas and trey Gowdy won
a discrete set of records about 200
related to the intelligence source and
whether their work was used in the
Russia case or to obtain surveillance
warrants on Carter page a Trump campaign
aide all we're asking for is give us the
documentation that you used to start
this investigation on the Senate floor
the Minority Leader said the president's
call for a parallel investigation set a
bad precedent President Trump seems to
have the terribly misguided view that
the Department of Justice is there to
protect his political interests and
prosecute his enemies the president's
lawyer Rudy Giuliani claims that earlier
this month he spoke with Special Counsel
Robert Muller about the investigation
ending by September 1st if the president
agreed to a mid-july interview Giuliani
said the two men also talked about the
alleged FBI informant Giuliani said
molars interview with the president
should be contingent on Giuliani having
access to the informant source familiar
with the discussion said tonight
lawmakers are waiting to learn more
details about the proposed meeting the
timing and weather all records requested
by Congress including those related to
an alleged FBI informant will be made
available Brett Kevin thank you